one of your very first tasks in animal  crossing will be to name your island  while there are a number of things in  new horizons you can tweak and change  along the way your island name isn't one  of them so be sure to brainstorm first  and go with something you'll be happy  with for the long haul if you plan on  using any of the game's online features  such as visiting other islands you  should know that others will be able to  see the name of your island so probably  best to go with something that won't  embarrass you later on your island name  will appear often and be referenced in  conversation between you and other  villagers if you're having trouble you  can always look to the internet for some  inspiration there are even random name  generators you can try and as a little  bonus tip here it's also worth noting  you cannot change your name or birthday  either